mr speaker our journey back towards
normality will be subject to resolving a
number
of key questions and to do this
we will conduct four reviews
one will assess how long we need to
maintain
social distancing and face masts
this will also inform guidance on
working from home
which should continue wherever possible
until this review
is complete and it will be critical in
determining how parliament can safely
return
in a way that i know honourable members
would wish
a second review will consider the
resumption
of international travel which is vital
for many businesses
which have been hardest hit including
retail hospitality tourism
and aviation a successor to the global
travel
task force will report by the 12th of
april
so that people can plan for the summer
the third review will consider the
potential role of covid status
certification inhaled in helping venues
to open safely but mindful of the many
concerns
surrounding exclusion discrimination and
privacy
and the fourth review will look at the
safe return of major events
mr speaker as we proceed through these
steps we will benefit from the combined
protection
of our vaccines and the continued
expansion of rapid testing
we will extend the provision of free
test kits for workplaces
until the end of june and families small
businesses
and the self-employed can collect those
tests
from local testing sites
mr speaker in view of these cautious but